ومن عنف الى عنف بس بدل ما هو اجتماعي
الان سياسي وعسكري الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه حدث عالمي كان من الاهم وللاسف
مستمر ومسيطر على الاخبار وملف كان من دون
شك من اكثر ما تكلم عنه العالم في 20 22
الاسماء الرو
سيه واقتراب قبول الحرب واحتماليات غزو
روسيا لاوكرانيا لشكل هذا اكثر موضوع
مسيطر على العالم وعناوين الاخبار الحرب
الاوكرانيه الروسيه ما بدات فعليا يعني
للان على الاقل بتتوقعوا انه روسيا
اوكرانيا بحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه وبدات العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه في الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه في
روسيا اليوم نفذت روسيا هجمات
الرئيس الروسي بوتن بوتر
مجموعه مدن اوكرانيه استخدام روسيا لهذه
الصواريخ تفجير اللي صار للجسر
الاستراتيجي والحرب العالميه الثالثه